welcome back to me rockstars I'm Eric
vos and Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness director scott derrickson
announced earlier this month that he was
departing as director citing the super
clear no follow-ups explanation of
creative differences as a huge fan of
Derek's ins work this was a bummer de
year and as in past cases when Disney
parted ways with directors like Edgar
Wright and Lord Miller I wondered if
this was just another case of studio
interference with bold directors who
don't want to play ball with the
intensity of their precious cinematic
universes but as days pass new details
have emerged from the nooks and crannies
of social media that are actually
painting a clearer picture of what the
second Doctor Strange movie plot was
what those creative differences could be
and what the movie might be going
forward much of this information comes
from the clues tucked in the outspoken
Derek since Twitter history so that
gives us an excuse to do our best to
explain the rejected plot of Doctor
Strange of the multiverse madness in
another stars tweet damn okay let's time
stone the clock back to last summer when
dr. strained to the multiverse of
madness was announced at comic-con
it's got Derek send describe the project
this way but when I came and talked to
Kevin about doing a sequel I said I
don't want to do just another sequel to
do a sequel if I'm gonna do it it has to
go into the territory that drew me into
the Doctor Strange comics in the first
place which is how they dipped into the
Gothic and the horror and and the
horrific and we're gonna make the first
scary MCU films rewatching this moment
it's fun to dive way too deep in the
body language of these two men the
moment derrickson says the word horror
Maggie
takes an uneasy step backward which
might be nothing but keep watching
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know you know why
no it's pg-13 you're gonna like it huh
maybe I'm losing it but have we just
picked up on figis poker tell with that
ear tug and it's almost like Feige could
not wait to backpedal on the dark horror
promises of derrickson derrickson who
before coming to the MCU made horror
films like sin stir and The Exorcism of
Emily Rose with foggy reassuring
everyone that this would still be a
family-friendly MCU adventure that we're
used to
still with a title like the multiverse
madness many of us speculated on the
cosmic horror influences derrickson
could be drawing on like HP Lovecraft's
at the mountains of madness where john
carpenter's in the mouth of madness then
jumping ahead to September 10th in which
derrickson tweeted based on both my own
experience and a recent conversation
with five other tentpole directors the
most common challenge / difficulty for
event movie filmmakers is getting
unwanted major script changes late in
pre-production now we don't know exactly
what derrickson was referring to here
about a month later it was reported that
Marvel Studios hired Jade Halle Bartlet
to write a draft of multiverse of Manas
Bartlet wrote the latest draft of the
horror film the turning now previously
it was assumed that Derrick's ins
collaborator for the first Doctor
Strange film novelist and screenwriter
see Robert Cargill would be returning to
write the sequel script and often with
Marvel films they'll bring in multiple
screenwriters to do passes like Thor
Ragnarok had at least half a dozen
screenwriters taking stabs at it
throughout development but then
derrickson posted more tweets that now
looking back seem a little suspect like
on December 16th he tweeted studio
release dates are the enemy of art ooh
two days after that he tweeted most
major life choices come with major
regrets it's unavoidable but the worst
choice is not choosing at all hell is
sitting down at the crossroads hell huh
regrets huh choices huh all these words
could mean something but all of this led
to an interesting update from Kevin
Feige on the multiverse of madness but
before I continue this video is brought
to you by Marvel collect my tops unlock
a world where you can collect and trade
Marvel characters bring your collection
light by earning rewards for completing
sets straight in lower level or
duplicate cards to receive more special
limited ones and much more new
collectibles are released and breed
eight more
collect buy toss is available both in
the iTunes App Store and Google Play
Store worldwide and it's free to
download and free to play December was
Fan Appreciation Month and is celebrated
in app tops digital gave away one free
collectible every day of the month and
five fan appreciation character cards
located in the free section of the pack
store I collected all five of the fant
appreciation cards finally nabbing that
Thor one to complete my set by
completing the sets new rock stars fans
were entered for a chance to win a
$1,000 worth of disney.com gift cards
$250 Midtown comics digital gift card
and then 10,000 diamonds in the in-app
currency and the winner of the contest
was AJ brass username a ji Z 14 Congrats
AJ and a big shout out to any of you
were super tissa pated now the contest
is over but there are brand new cards as
part of the new 2020 Bay series allowing
Marvel fans around the world to relive
the nostalgia of card collecting and
flipping them over to learn more about
each character to marvel collect bye
tops it's still a blast to play just
click on the link in the description to
download the marvel collect app register
a username and then collect the 5 and
appreciation cars located in the free
section of the pack store be sure to
follow at tops marble on twitter and at
tops digital on instagram download
marble collect buy tops digital trading
card app to start collecting and trading
your favorite characters with fans
around the world the app is free to play
and new cards are released every day
download now from the link below okay
back to pikeys Doctor Strange update
during a recent Q&A Feige echoed that
perceived uneasiness during Comic Con
about classifying Doctor Strange to as
pure horror genre multiverse of madness
is the greatest title we've ever come up
with by the way which is one thing
that's exciting about it and I wouldn't
necessarily say that's a horror film but
it is as scott derrickson our director
has pitched it it is it'll be a big MCU
film with scary
sequences in it the way when I was a kid
in the 80s Spielberg did an amazing job
I mean there are horrifying sequences in
Raiders that I would say there's a
little kid and do this when their face
is melted or Temple of Doom of course or
gremlins or poltergeist these are these
are the movies that invented the pg-13
rating by the way they were PG and then
they were like we need another but
that's fun it's fun to be scared in that
way and not a
not a you know horrific torturous way
but in a way that is legitimately scary
cuz scott derrickson is quite good at
that but scary in the service of an
exhilarating emotion aha Mikey makes an
important distinction here his favorite
horror influences are the ones of Steven
Spielberg's Amblin world in which dark
horrifying supernatural events occur but
stories typically balance out at the end
with a nice sweetness to them an
implication that there is a God in the
world it's a good place if you watch
your step
based on what I know about Scott
Derrickson his horror influences are
more closely tied to John Carpenter's
Stephen King HP Lovecraft the world is a
dark place in which sometimes
inexplicably bad things happen to
innocent people and there's no logic to
it hell is real and we're living in it
buguese words from @qa were followed by
a few surprising announcements in early
January of this year one that one
division which was previously intended
to tie into the multiverse of madness
was moved up from spring 2021 to
sometime this year in 2020 second
announcement the nearly scrapped did
x-men horror spin-off the new mutants
would in fact be linked to the MCU and
three-d-- Erickson's announcement that
he's leaving dr. change too and one
interesting response to that was a tweet
from filmmaker ISA Lopez the following
day she was brought up by a fan as a
replacement director maybe and Lopez
said that she could never fill
derrickson shoes and she said that the
last thing Marvel would want is a
deranged mexicana with a penchant for
ghosts which prevents opening in China
unconventional storytelling and a
political agenda and derrickson liked to
this tweet Lopez is referring to how
Hollywood studios these days are
increasingly catering to the Chinese
film board which censors material to
their audiences that may come off in
their eyes as unflattering to the
Chinese government preventing some films
from making hundreds of millions more
from the lucrative Chinese market Iron
Man 3 aired a different kind of movie
that included Chinese friendly scenes no
movies with Brad Pitt or Richard Gere
can release in China because they were
previously in movies that were critical
of China and there were rumors at the
first Doctor Strange movie cast Tilda
Swinton as the ancient one instead of
the characters Tibetan comic origin in
order to appease China which has a
complicated political relationship with
Tibet and in this case ghosts in the
supernatural are also kind of tricky
subjects for China like the horror film
crimson
ich was barred from Chinese release
apparently because it featured ghosts
though Chinese filmmakers have pointed
out that positive depictions of spirits
and ghosts would probably be okay but
that in Chinese culture according to
them negative and demonic entities have
been associated with corrupt government
officials so perhaps all the sheds light
on derricks ins original plan for the
multiverse of madness and why he parted
ways with Marvel the most speculated
villains that derrickson had brought up
have been figures like nightmare in
Mephisto who are straight up demons in
the Marvel world nightmare comes from
the dream dimension their existence
brings that the existence of Marvel held
Erickson's multiverse of madness could
have looked something like mande revenge
horizon with the sorcerer supreme
without the time stone super vulnerable
to protect this dimension from evil
ghostly entities and then the hands
grope and Stephen strange in the
multiverse so revealed to be those of
serial killers from the bottom ring of
Hell your kids are screaming buddy you
know you love it really the further
horror derrickson wanted to go maybe the
more he would risk depriving Marvel's
big may 2021 hand pole release from
hundreds of millions in China
essentially if Disney as a studio wants
to continue reigning supreme in the box
office cash so they can afford their big
Fox buyout and maybe someday buying out
Stoney Spiderman properties none of
their movies can ever go to hell now it
is worth noting back into September
Dirks and retweeted an animated gif of
Walt Disney's 1929 shorts hells bells
depicting Satan and his demons gathering
for a wild party Cerberus is here it's
lit and you can imagine goth filmmakers
pining for an era when Disney wasn't so
limited on the hellish depths that could
explore that Plus disputes of rewrites
plus Marvel's strict release schedule
deadlines might have just made this
project too untenable for derrickson and
now instead of one division being tied
to a horror project like multiverse of
madness I think we may now be looking at
a connection to the New Mutants which
has softer pg-13 horror and now maybe a
post-credits scene that links it with
the MCU
meanwhile fighty hinted at a new
direction for multiverse of madness and
not just to shift its horror elements
from Lovecraft to Amblin but also in
general to emphasize the multiverse over
the madness the next Doctor Strange film
for instance features some new MCU
characters that will be making their
debut in that movie that you won't
expect or won't guess who it is
but we
founded cool way to make it work because
we needed a particular we will want to
make a particular type of movie there
and there was a character we always
wanted to do something with who we think
will fit really well there
unexpected new hims new characters
sounds to me that multiverse of madness
will be less of a journey into hell than
a journey into the new brighter MCU
multiverse to introduce figures maybe
like Reed Richards or the mutants I know
who do you think this new character will
be and what director do you want to
replace scott derrickson for multiverse
of madness should we stick with horror
directors good at nerdy adaptation like
guillermo del toro or peter jackson Sam
Raimi James Wan or should they really
turn the page comment down below with
your thoughts on this follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA boss follow
new rock stars in social media and
subscribe to new rockstars for
explanations of all the biggest
mysteries in the multiverse also be sure
to check out our new Q&A series the big
question in which Phillip and I give you
too much information that how freaky
these Marvel characters are when you
think about them in the real world like
how Captain America will one day bury us
all thank you for joining me
[Music]